okay good morning and welcome today's
discussion about quantum computing in
canada and germany as part of berlin
science week this event is one of 50
events celebrating 50 years of canadian
germany cooperation and science and
technology my name is peter mason
director of the newly launched quantum
centers challenge program at the
national research council of canada and
i'll be your master of ceremonies today
i would like to begin by acknowledging
that the national research council
occupies many of the traditional
territories of many first nations metis
peoples and inuit whose ancestral
footsteps and rights extend beyond the
colonial boundaries that exist today we
respectfully honor these people's rights
history and relationships with this land
we will open today with some words from
canada's ambassador to germany stefan
dion
the honourable stefan dion is the
ambassador to germany and special envoy
to the european union in europe he
presented his credentials as canada's
ambassador to germany in 2017 mr dion
was canada's minister of foreign affairs
and he championed canada's leadership in
the world on crucial global interests
including promotion of universal human
rights peace and stability efforts the
global climate challenge and canada's
commitment to multiculturalism and
multilateralism previously he was
minister of the environment minister
responsible for official languages
minister of intergovernmental affairs
and also chaired the united nations
conference on climate change mr dion
ladies and gentlemen by the dominus
canada
are we on the eve of a new quantum
revolution
it appears to be the case with promises
of a radically different future from the
world for the from the world we know
today
the quantum properties of materials open
up countless new opportunities in areas
as varied as manufacturing
healthcare the environment mobility
communications transportation navigation
defense and cyber security there is
virtually no limit to people's
creativity when it comes to new
applications of quantum technologies
capable of solving problems of process
optimization and simulation out of reach
for conventional computer
but for this revolution to come true
these two leading high-tech leaders that
are germany and canada must strengthen
their partnership
and so thank you all of you for joining
this exciting session of the berlin
science week titled canada germany
quantum computing
i'm always thrilled to join berlin
science week which brings together the
world's most innovative scientific
organizations to celebrate and promote
science
but this year i am especially thrilled
given the immense potential of our
cooperation in quantum technology
and it's great that we have chosen this
crucial topic quantum technology
precisely as we celebrate this year the
50th anniversary of the agreement on
science and technology between canada
and germany
for 50 years our countries have
supported more than a thousand
collaborative scientific projects which
have spanned the spectrum of research to
bring together our government
research institutes universities
non-profit organizations and businesses
today's event will shed light on the
tremendous opportunities to be found in
quantum
computing
canada which ranks first in per capita
spending of overall in quantum computing
research
canada has recently launched a 360
million dollar national quantum strategy
which will build on previous investments
by bolstering support for this
burgeoning sector
canada will be a great partner for
germany in what is projected to become a
world
daughter industry over the next three
decades
and as i pass the floor to our recent
selection of speakers and panelists i
want to thank all of you
for your participation
and please
please keep up the inspiring and
important work
thank you so much
finland
merci
merci beaucoup mr dion
we now welcome remarks from dr genjiev
tange vice president of the national
research council
in 2016 dr jean-viv tange joined the
national research council of canada as
the first woman vice president of
research she leads the emerging
technologies division which oversees
nanotechnology metrology astronomy and
astrophysics security and disruptive
technologies and advanced electronics
and photonics dr tange also serves as
the canadian co-chair of the canada
germany joint science and technology
cooperation committee prior to joining
the national research council she served
as vice rector research creativity and
innovation at the university of montreal
and also served as the assistant deputy
minister responsible for research
innovation science and society in the
government of quebec dr thank you
good morning and good afternoon amazon
hermannell honored guests and colleagues
kitten tag
i'm honored to be here with you today
and be part of opening this remarkable
event that is an exciting feature of the
berlin science week
first off i would like to thank the
organizers of this event the embassy of
canada and berlin and nrc germany in
munich
the science technology and innovation
relationship between canada and germany
runs deep we have been collaborating
with german researchers and scientists
for several decades and i'm thrilled to
say that we're celebrating the 50th
anniversary of signing the canada
germany treaty for scientific and
technological cooperation this year
to strengthen our remarkable
relationship the nrc laid roots in
germany in december 2019 by establishing
a post at the canadian consulate in
munich led by dr jennifer decker
we are eager to deepen our snt
partnerships with germany including in
the area of quantum technologies
currently we have a number of
collaborative projects in quantum
sensing which you will hear more about
later in today's agenda
worldwide countries and governments are
recognizing the power of quantum
technologies quantum promises to be
among the next enabling and foundational
technological platforms spanning
multiple applications in all industries
including healthcare energy finance
telecom
and more
quantum computing holds the potential to
solve complex problems
exponentially more quickly than existing
computers
in some cases quantum computers are able
to efficiently solve problems that are
completely intractable on classical
computers
they can help solve some complex math
and simulations necessary to advance
engineering and other areas of science
as quantum computing technologies
continue to rapidly progress the need to
enhance cyber security and build quantum
safe systems to secure infrastructures
and economies will also be
increasingly critical
i hope that the insight generated from
today's event will spark ongoing
interaction between our two nations on
the possibilities that quantum computing
technologies hold for our respective
societies
we are so pleased to be part of this
event and i'm sure we will continue
growing our engagement efforts with
germany and quantum computing and beyond
events like this one are critical to
help us understand the challenges our
nations are dealing with and to help
advance standardized practical quantum
computing
for widespread applications have a
wonderful day and i look forward to
hearing about the fantastic outcomes
from the berlin science week
next up is mr fritjov medal who is the
deputy director general for
international cooperation in education
and research german federal ministry of
education and research also known as
bmbf in 1992 he joined the federal
ministry for research and technology
today's federal ministry of education
and research where he held various
positions he worked in the internal
market and information society
directorates general at the european
commission in brussels mr menell was
appointed head of the strategy division
at the federal ministry of education and
research in 2007. later on he was
appointed head of the directorate for
international cooperation at the federal
ministry of education and research mr
menno
spears from the canadian and german
science and innovation community
i'm honored to welcome you on behalf of
the german federal ministry of education
and research to this event on quantum
computing at the berlin science week
as my colleague tongay from the national
research council of canada already
pointed out this event as part of the
50th anniversary of our science
and technology agreement that has been
signed in 1971.
jubilee we as bmbf are very proud of
there are very few countries in this
world
where we have such a long lasting and
formalized collaboration in science
than with canada
the quality and liveliness of our
collaboration with canada is outstanding
and covers nearly all areas and all
disciplines of scientific research
at that time in the early 70s when the
contract was signed probably no one of
the high-level representatives of both
countries had an idea what quantum
technology or quantum computing might be
no one has probably anticipated that it
will be one of the most thrilling
research areas science has to offer
in the third decade of this century
that demonstrates at least two things
first
in science and innovation it's difficult
to predict the future
and elsewhere of course secondly
one of the many strengths of the
mutually beneficial collaboration
between our two countries
is our ability to adapt quickly to new
priorities
and research areas that have the
potential for new insights
or new technological pathways
with no doubt the full potential of
quantum technologies is not yet fully
unfolded
and quantum like
artificial intelligence
has the potential to be a game changer
for science as well as for our economies
to foster the development and use of
quantum technologies
the german ghana government is combining
forces to cover the whole value chain
from basic research to market access
for quantum technologies
in our recent framework program and for
the coming years there are approximately
3 billion euros earmarked for the
support of quantum technologies covering
eg computing system
and use case development a communication
pilot network
and lighthouse projects in sensing and
metrology
from these initiatives we will build a
strong ecosystem with academia and
industry
international collaboration is an
inherent element of our national
research strategies
and canada is of course
one of the leading nations in quantum
computing today
in the last two to three years we had
several joint funding activities with
canada in areas like added value
manufacturing
ai and hydrogen research
just to name a few
and i'm convinced that the excellent
scientists on both sides of the atlantic
are not running short of ideas for new
collaborations
i am wishing all of you for this event a
lot of new insights on the quantum
ecosystems of both countries
and interesting discussions with your
colleagues
finally i'd like to thank the nrc and
the canadian embassy for organizing the
event
and inviting us to be a partner
thank you mr mental we will now have our
first lecture of the program which will
be a technological technology overview
of quantum computing given by dr phil k
dr k is the program director of the
national research council's applied
quantum computing challenge program he
served in a variety of roles within the
government of canada's communication
security establishment primarily as a
trusted advisor on the impacts of
quantum technologies he also worked for
the canadian quantum computing company
d-wave systems as program director of
corporate affairs
phil co-founded and chaired quantum
industry canada a consortium
representing over 24 canadian quantum
technology companies
presently phil is serving as the program
director of the national research
council's new applied quantum computing
challenge program where i've had the
privilege of working with him over the
last year and a half phil over to you
thank you peter
so this will be a quick technology
overview just to sort of set the table
for um the following
rest of the
morning uh so next slide please
so early in the 20th century as
physicists
explored nature and probe nature at
scales of you know increasingly small
scales
it started to realize that that nature
behaved in ways that were very very
remarkably different than
we were accustomed to
and in fact
ways that are very counter to intuition
and sort of our common sense view of of
how the world behaves and so the story
here is that quantum physics is uh very
very different from classical physics
it's it's not simply about changing some
parameters in your equations it's about
a whole new paradigm for uh for how
nature behaves and so that's it's very
important to realize that when you're
thinking about quantum technologies next
slide please
so
physics and the natural sciences are of
course they're about understanding how
understanding and predicting how nature
behaves uh
and and um
you know and and modeling that um and as
our understanding of
um of nature
develops we then turn that that
understanding into technology which is
about harnessing and controlling the
behavior of nature to do useful things
and so
in the 1930s of course um quantum
physics began uh
replace while replacing but superseding
classical physics is our understanding
of how nature behaves at a microscopic
scale and more recently in the last
two to three decades we've been turning
that understanding into an ability to
manipulate the physical world at a
quantum mechanical level and to
harness some of these some of these very
different behaviors to do
useful tasks in ways that are very very
different and cannot be done classically
broadly speaking you can classify
quantum technologies into three sort of
categories
much as we do with classical
technologies there are computing
technologies quantum computing
technologies there are quantum
communications technologies and of
course there are quantum sensing
technologies next slide please
so quantum computing uh is of course
about
um solving prob solving information
theoretic problems using a computer uh
and what a quantum computer is uh as dr
sango tange
explained a quantum computer is about
harnessing quantum mechanics to do
computations in fundamentally new ways
which for certain classes of problems
are able to outperform uh the best known
uh classical computing approaches
communications of course is about using
uh
using some of the features of quantum
mechanics to perform certain
communications tasks uh
that that are impossible classically uh
or in ways that are more efficient than
you can do classically and one of those
tasks is about secure communications
quantum mechanics allows provides a new
set of tools for communicating securely
uh that provides some capabilities that
we don't have access to with classical
technology
and finally quantum sensors
um in fact i probably should have put
quantum sensors at the top of the list
because in some sense quantum sensors
are the closest to having uh
you know a real world commercial impact
um
the idea of a quantum sensor is roughly
speaking a quantum system quantum a
quantum mechanical system is very very
sensitive to its environment and for
building quantum computers for example
that can be a a significant challenge um
because to protect the system's
properties and the system and the
quantum systems behavior we have to
shield it from its environment very
carefully while still controlling it but
you can turn that around of course if
the system is so sensitive to its
environment why not use it to sense the
environment and that is exactly what
quantum sensors are about and quantum
sensors can
be developed that can sense a variety of
signals uh including gravitational
signals electromagnetic signals light uh
and and can do so
um
with a sensitivity that goes beyond a
fundamental limit that classical sensors
face called the the quantum limit or the
classical limit
next slide please
so quantum computers uh
so as with any computing technology
you've got hardware and you've got
software so let's talk a little bit
about the hardware this is it's still
early days really for for quantum
computers um
you know the quantum computers are still
um
um
well they may always be but they're
still you know room size um
systems uh and and in fact it's still
not clear uh which
what type of physical technology is
going to win the day uh going forward
for for realizing
what we call scalable fault tolerant
quantum computers
of the future uh the current quantum
computers that we have uh
are being explored with a variety of
technologies superconducting qubits that
are cooled down to extremely low
temperatures are some of the more common
uh commonly explored technologies for
implementing quantum computers another
approach is to trap is ion traps and
honeywell for example is building
machines
of that type
uh this is the current state-of-the-art
systems we call noisy intermediate scale
quantum or nisq nisk and they've got you
know right now about 100 cubits
and for the next few years we're
probably going to be in the hundreds of
qubits
um depending on of course on
on on how fast the
people are able to
uh to scale these things but scaling
them is a huge challenge um
but they are getting to an interesting
state where now the the niskon computers
that are appearing are actually of a
size and complexity beyond which we can
simulate classically meaning their
behavior is now um offering the
potential for truly novel capabilities
uh when we get when we want to get to
truly um large-scale quantum computers
that can run some of the
the really transformative uh
applications that
that we know about we're going to
require
what we call fault tolerance which is
basically error correction
and the reason for that one of the
reasons for that is that quantum
computers
more so than classical computers are
very very susceptible to noise and
errors
and there's a huge overhead that's
required
to um to redundantly encode uh
information in a quantum computer to
correct for those errors and stay ahead
of them
and
so to achieve fault tolerance
we're likely going to need to scale up
from where we are now with nisk to
systems that have millions of physical
quantum bits
uh next slide please
oh next slide we'll skip this one short
on time um so software
um
the other side of quantum computing of
course is software so one thing to
understand is a quantum computer is not
just a souped-up computer that runs your
your python program uber fast a quantum
computer is a is a new type of system
that
um
that operates in ways that are that are
qualitatively different than a classical
computer and a quantum algorithm uh is
sort of a a program that runs on a
quantum computer is something that you
can't run on a classical computer
because
the way even the very nature of uh the
information contained within a quantum
computer is fundamentally different uh
in in a classical computer your
information is is a digital it's in bits
binary digits ones and zeros in a
quantum computer you have what are
called quantum bits where you can have
arbitrary superpositions a quantum bit
can be a one or a zero or some
superposition of one and zero
and that is a very important
difference
and
one of the one of the things about a
quantum algorithm is that
it's very very tricky to
um
to design a quantum algorithm that
cannot perform the best classical
logarithms for a problem because they
really have to exploit the structure of
a problem they're solving uh
very specifically and one of the ways of
thinking about how a quantum computer
can achieve a computational advantage is
to
sort of explore multiple computation
paths in parallel in superposition
and then to use what's called
interference to uh
to have sort of the
the answers that don't line up with the
correct answer that you're looking for
sort of cancel each other out and the
computational paths that results in the
in the correct answers sort of uh
reinforce each other and you can see
that
i mean that's very tricky to arrange um
you have to really understand the
problem you're solving and so the point
i want to make here is that quantum
algorithms research is really really
hard um
and and um there's a lot of work still
to be done and a lot of things that we
still need to learn about uh what
problems are going to be amenable to
quantum speed up
next slide
please so uh quantum cryptography um
sorry uh the quantum threat to
cryptography um
one of the
first
um one of the quantum applications
applications of a quantum computer that
made her first that first made a big
splash uh
in a sense was called shores algorithm
uh owing to peter shore and it solved a
problem called uh order finding or
factoring uh
um and that problem under under
underlies the security of all the uh
public cryptography that's used around
the world to uh secure the internet for
authentication um basically everything
we do online is protected ultimately by
some form of public key cryptography
once we have these um fully scalable
fault tolerant quantum computers uh all
of that is going to be vulnerable
uh and so the basic idea is with public
key cryptography is that encrypting uh
information is easy and anybody can
encrypt information with a public key
but going the other way and decrypting
is hard unless you have a secret key the
private key
and so for classical computers
encrypting is easy
next slide please
sorry i hit the spacebar for the slide
and i'm muted um
so a large scale fault tolerant quant
computer of course running shore's
algorithm will make code breaking easy
even without the secret key and that's a
huge problem next slide please
so how do we solve that problem well
there are two basic approaches one is to
to use those features of quantum
mechanics and i talked about quantum
communications uh so there's a
technology called quantum quantum key
distribution qkd and it allows you to do
um it allows you to to
establish secret keys uh secret
encryption keys
in an alternative way to uh public key
cryptography using quantum technologies
and qkd can offer an unprecedented level
of security that you can't get with any
classical technology and another
approach is to replace the current suite
of public key cryptography
algorithms that we have uh with new ones
that are built on math problems that we
that aren't vulnerable to shores
algorithm and that we believe will not
be vulnerable to quantum computer
attacks of the future and so those are
two very different approaches next slide
please
quantum key distribution um of course
one of the challenges of qkd is that
it's a physical layer technology uh
meaning you have to have specialized
hardware uh and um you know for example
you can't
i don't think you can do it over um over
copper so you can't do it over ethernet
you need optical fibers or uh you can do
it through free space uh it's also
distance limited you can't um you have
to have sort of trusted nodes every 150
kilometers or so uh or you can use a
satellite
[Music]
to overcome the distance limitation but
again these are these are significant
deployment challenges
next slide please
quantum resistant cryptography of course
uh is a software-based solution uh you
replace the existing suite of uh of
crypto uh algorithms in your you know in
all of your computers and all of your
devices uh and so it's uh it doesn't
have the same deployment limitations and
challenges
um you know it works over ip networks
the same as uh all of our existing
crypto uh but it is vulnerable to what's
called a record now and decrypt later
attack which means that um
which means that potentially
um sorry my alarm is going after which
means potentially um
if
using using public key cryptography
using um quantum resistant cryptography
is potentially vulnerable to um to
somebody recording the transmission and
then decrypting it later uh so it's
vulnerable to unforeseen future advances
in um
in computation
uh but there but there is a nist
standardization process underway and we
will see uh new suites of quantum
resistant cryptography solutions being
deployed around the world in the years
ahead next slide please
um i'll skip the slide because i am kind
of out of time
this final thing i'll say is that
quantum quantum computing quantum
cryptography uh quantum communications
and quantum sensing are all being
commercialized uh both in germany and in
canada uh and both countries have a
robust and growing um
uh commercial sector for quantum
technologies uh there are challenges of
course one of which not the least of
which is uh
a
a
tech talent shortage
or a tech talent uh
limitation
we need more people we need to train
more people that understand these
technologies that can develop
new quantum technologies
and um of course we have you know
wonderful institutions in both countries
that are uh that are working hard to
fill that gap certification programs
need to be developed so that we can uh
certify uh expertise uh and companies
you know we need to be able to assess
companies um so that we can pick winners
uh next slide i think i'm
at the end here great uh yes so of
course i'd be delighted to chat with
anybody at any time and uh thank you for
for listening and uh it's been a
pleasure and it is a pleasure to uh to
join you today
thanks so much phil
so if you're wondering how phil became
so smart and knowledgeable you don't
need to wait very long for an answer
because we will now be hearing from
phil's former phd supervisor dr michele
mosca a well-known international expert
in the field professor mosca is co-chair
of quantum industry canada and
co-founder of the institute for quantum
computing at the university of waterloo
a professor in the department of
combinatorics and optimization of the
faculty of mathematics and a founding
member of waterloo's perimeter institute
for theoretical physics
in particular about the quantum
computing ecosystem with a focus on
quantum computing i think we've already
seen that it's part of a broader quantum
information technology ecosystem but the
focus today
um will center on quantum computing
and you know back in 1999 uh
there was certainly there was about
there's a handful of people who'd done
seminal work in quantum algorithms and
complexity
inventing you know quantum key
distribution co-inventing it
uh
among the inventors of quantum
teleportation
pioneers in in qubits in optical systems
and so on
so it was a small number but the field
was small back then and canada was
already you know powerhouse uh around
the world
in quantum computing
fast forward you know 22 years
and now we have over 100 we're in the
hundreds in terms of professors in this
area we're well we're into the thousands
now in terms of students and post-docs
working in this field uh we're moving
into the innovation space there's
incubators and so on there's
multi-sector it's not just
multi-disciplinary research now there's
multi-sector collaborations going on all
across canada from the new quantum
algorithms institute out west
to antique over in quebec and so on um
and now you know the companies across
canada have come together into an
association and over a third of those
companies are on computing related i'll
talk a bit about more of that more about
that soon
um i want to echo something you know
phil k had mentioned
and it's relevant to quantum computing
because
in order to benefit from all the
positive things quantum computing will
bring
we must make sure it won't you know of
course decimate our digital platforms
and undermine all the other valuable
things we enjoy today in canada and
germany
are really stand as global leaders
true global leaders in this getting
ready for a safe quantum future safe
quantum computing future and there's a
here's a long list
board from one of bridget walsh's
walsh's presentations of the many
government industry academic academia
collaborations to help prepare not just
canada but the world so we can just
safely we can in an unencumbered way uh
enjoy the benefits of quantum computing
i mean the alternative it won't be won't
be good so we don't want to go there
and germany is also you know again one
of the true shining lights and i use
this in all my presentations
in germany i was actually honored to be
you know one of the keynote speakers
at this event launching a number of
bambaya funded projects in post-quantum
cryptography
germany is also a leader in in quantum
key distribution there's a number of
initiatives i can't also list them all
and on the academic side with
long-standing collaborations between
canada and germany and the rest of the
world but i do think this is one of the
several areas where canada germany can
really be
together uh you know much stronger than
the sum of its parts
help create security and prosperity for
our citizens as well as the rest of the
world
now transitioning back to so
let's assume let's hope we work together
to make it safe to enjoy all the
benefits of quantum computing i can't
possibly list
everything that canada is doing all of
our strengths so i'll just give a couple
examples across the spectrum
um and broadbent now a professor at the
university of ottawa you know one of the
problems looking ahead you know over a
decade ago and
what where's the future heading and what
are the what are the fundamental
problems we need to address if we really
want to reap the rewards of quantum
computing well one is how do we do
quantum computing in the cloud when how
do we trust that we get the faithful
answer from the from someone else's
quantum computer how do we assure that
our information remains private the part
of the information that needs to remain
confidential and so on and she pioneered
a very fundamental framework for
allowing this sort of blind quantum
computing
and
this of course is now becoming a
commercially interesting uh you know
technology and capability in fact she's
an advisor to a startup that is working
in this space
so this whole ecosystem is starting to
to come together into gel and there's an
incubator in toronto for example that
helps to start up
startups get off the ground
another example of great fundamental
research being driven in canada today is
from professor stephanie simmons now at
simon fraser university in british
columbia
she's working on building quantum bits
out of certain spin-based systems
a wide range of very you know important
work published in world's top journals
she's also thinking about not just the
fundamental research but also how will
it be applied how can it be used
right and she's
written some thoughtful pieces about the
commercialization landscape and she's
even the church chief quantum officer at
a company that spun out of her work
this is sort of
examples and there's many many others
across canada
not necessarily always the same person
but this this pipeline from fundamental
to applied to innovation to
commercialization to adoption
right that is that has been evolving in
canada for decades now and it's a very
rich environment
we have
and it's recognized our commercial
ecosystem is is recognized around the
world
um again over 30 companies now this is
already an outdated collection of logos
um but the quantum computing companies
which are a big part of our quantum
industry include companies looking at
applications of quantum computing of
course d-wave started this many years
ago with their quantum annealing
technologies and now other companies
are again on the front lines
of application areas
others are
either in addition to or alternatively
looking at the quantum software tools
that will bridge the applications to the
hardware other companies are looking at
you know the software or the hardware
itself for quantum computing
and a vast a quickly growing array of
companies in this space also companies
on the quantum safe side of the equation
again to prepare for the safe quantum
era
and we're it's it's a growing uh
supportive ecosystem there's a broad
recognition in canada that this requires
you know all these different elements to
work together coherently
and there's a national quantum strategy
being launched it's already been
announced and underway uh i already
mentioned some of the elements we have
going for us in canada again this is not
an exhaustive list just to be clear but
i want to highlight some examples like
the quantum algorithms institute a new
initiative bringing together the
academic and industry activities the
incubators
there's many canadian government
programs to support this initiative
and so again this is just two examples
especially focus on quantum computing
there's this great innovation solutions
canada program
which is starting and we expect it will
accelerate its support of
the adoption of these quantum
technologies and quantum enabled
technologies and there's a new just a
brand new program uh led out of nrc now
called the applied quantum computing
challenge so as you can see we have this
this full ecosystem i mean rapidly
growing um and we see many great
synergies
definitely historically there have been
many and i see sort of a
three great pillars of where canada and
germany can really work together
to great create greater prosperity and
security for our own citizens
and also uh bring that those
opportunities to the rest of the world
in the quantum safe side
in in sort of the the research side of
the equation and also the
commercialization side
and i really look forward to the rest of
the talks today and to ongoing future
collaborations uh with our friends in
germany
great many thanks for the overview
mckelly and also for your leadership uh
in quantum physics in canada over the
last couple of decades
our next lecture on the german quantum
computing ecosystem will be given by
dr tatiana wilk dr wilk is the general
manager of the munich center for quantum
science and technology which is a
cluster of excellence funded by the
german research foundation before that
she worked for several years as a senior
researcher at the max planck institute
of quantum optics on single atom cavity
quantum electrodynamics dr wilk enjoys
working on forming a strong quantum
community in munich on connecting
academia and industry in bavaria on
strengthening education in quantum
engineering and on engaging the public
in quantum technology which
is what she's here to do today thanks dr
wilk
thank you very much
peter it's a pleasure for me to be here
and share with you um
our
our thoughts about the german quantum
ecosystem
quantum computing ecosystem
um
just recently the the german quantum
technology
got a boost from a boost of funding
from from the german federal government
which announced
as as part of the economic recovery plan
after the corona crisis
about a funding of of 2 billion euros
actually for the development and
production of quantum technologies in
germany
so
they do not only want to to fund
research but also the production of
quantum technologies which is important
the new industrial pillar
based on quantum technology should cover
hardware as well as software
and it is important that
the excellent research that is going on
already in germany is transferred to
product
development
moreover germany wants to support the
foundation of companies and startups um
which
which is maybe
more which we could take as an example
from canada actually i really enjoyed
it
i really enjoyed mikila's talk about
the many companies
flourishing in in the canadian ecosystem
so um to do to do the funding in the
right way to to bring
the
funding into the right channels the
german federal government
asked 16 experts from academia and
industry to give their advice on how to
best invest into quantum technology
so they um
they
um
what they they first analyzed
the status quo of quantum technology
expertise
in germany and found that there is a
very strong expertise in in academia
but in
and as well industry is very strong in
basic and enabling technologies but a
comprehensive ecosystem is missing which
would
support a whole
supply chain of quantum technologies
also the level of ip and quantum
technology that is
found in in germany is is quite low and
there are only a few startups
moreover i mean we are we will soon miss
quantum smart
quantum smart workforce if we do not
invest in in
educating the next generation of quantum
engineers now
so their recommendation was to reinforce
the research centers that are existing
already in germany and focus their
activities in particularly on quantum
computing and to strongly interconnect
these activities with the german
industry
so
responsible for implementing this
program
are the
the ministry of education and research
the bmbf and as well as the ministry of
economic affairs and energy the bmwi
they share
the funds
almost equally and the bmbf
is
is
is calling or
is calling for applications at the
moment from
from research centers and from
new clusters that are formed from
academia and industry
with a with now a very strong focus on
quantum computing demonstrators and
quantum computing applications
um they have actually um also regarding
the the advice of the experts
put in a very
high technical requirements for these um
for these projects that which are
defined by the number of qubits that
will be
that will be addressed
the gate fidelities as well as
chromosomes as scalability of quantum
computing
hardware and
also the quantum advantage of quantum
software
and soon there will be more calls on
also on quantum metrology and sensing as
well as communication
for the bmwi
this looks a bit different they
put
about 85 percent of their funds into the
german aerospace center dlr
which acts actually as a project
managing
the office
as well as the research institutions so
they will distribute about 80 percent of
their funds
into industry so they will support
industry in in
developing quantum hardware and quantum
software
and they put 20 percent of the funds
into their own research and new
institutes that which are forming at the
moment
moreover there are other
projects
supported by bmwi
such as a platform planck and a platform
and ecosystem for quantum assisted
artificial intelligence then there is a
quantum technology competence center
which
serves as an access point for quantum
technology expertise
for
for industry which which for people who
would like to
to apply uh quantum technologies or to
founder companies
then there is also the national space
program which looks for quantum
technology applications for states
actually in germany there are many
traditionally very many
research centers all over germany so
this is a map from
the source is the the faulty technician
[Music]
and there are many excellent research
groups with various expertise so we have
experts in
in neutral atom quantum simulation
in a superconducting qubit quantum
computing in
quantum computing based on
based on trapped ions
and also on spin cubits or also on
photonics
in in the european union almost every
every fifth uh quantum technology
research group comes from germany
so we have many national and
international projects running already
and there are universities and research
institutions that work together
the
we have classes of excellence such as
ourselves the mcqsd and other research
centers and there is also a grassroot
initiative like the quantum alliance
which is actually an association
of um of different clusters of
excellence
and research centers throughout germany
and now i would like to point out our
strategy in munich just as an example
since other
centers are
have are following a similar strategy
so in munich we have formed there was an
initiative that was formed
by the
two large universities in munich the
ludwig maximilian the university of
munich at the technical university of
munich
founding member will be as well the
frederick alexander university in
ireland nuremberg
and the max planck society the
fraunhofer society as well as the parish
academy media business
the idea of the munich quantum valley is
to to follow a comprehensive quantum
strategy so they want to build actually
quantum computers based on
iron trap quantum computers and neutral
atoms um as well as superconducting
qubits and they will also launch
flagship projects
or lighthouse projects
um then there will be infrastructure
that will be um installed um
deeptek infrastructure which will be
open to universities to startups and to
to companies and which will be connected
to the labs of fraunhofer and the max
bank society
moreover in munich we are already
building
the quantum smart workforce um we have a
master's course on quantum science and
technology running um just recently a
project launched that is retraining
or will will be retraining engineers
from industry
and we are doing outreach activities
here you see a bit more detailed the
consortia
of the munich quantum valley so we have
a consortium covering superconducting
qubits uh trapped atom counter computing
so neutral atom as well as iron
ions
then there is a theory
we also have software and integration
we have a consortium looking for
scalable hardware and system engineering
another consortium covering quantum
algorithm
quantum algorithms for applications and
and cloud and industry
and also hardware adapted theory
moreover as i already mentioned there
will be lighthouse projects covering
other quantum technologies um and there
is a
a plan for um
education in riveria not only for
students at universities and not only
for the workforce
but also we would like to bring quantum
technology already to schools
um moreover there is another project
which covers the quantum technology park
and entrepreneurship so where we want to
enforce
startup landscape here in in bavaria or
in germany in general
um so we have been very lucky in munich
that the free state of bavaria is
supporting the munich quantum valley and
already announced that a support of
about 300 million euros
and in a recent visit angela merkel
was
told us that
the federal government will also
contribute to the munich content valley
so the calls are still running so we
don't know how much funding we will
receive
but there will be more to come but what
i would like to point out that this was
of course only an example so there are
other centers in in germany such as the
quantum valley lower saxony which covers
um university in hanover and the the
technical university in braunschweig and
the
ptp the
there is also a center forming in in and
around julie and of course the dlr
centers in ulm and hamburg and many
others
but we have a very strong quantum
community in germany with a very
with regular exchanges um on research
topics as well as on strategies
so with this i would like to summarize
there is a very
strong effort in germany going on
and please stay tuned projects are
starting soon and first results are
expected in in about five years thank
you very much
and many thanks to you dr wilk for this
overview of the german quantum computing
ecosystem it's uh it's quite a
quite a fascinating topic so much money
being invested in things happening
quickly
um
we'll move on now to our panel
discussion where our panel of experts
answer questions about quantum computing
the panel will be moderated by dr julie
lefeve of the national research council
of canada dr lefeve joined the national
research council as director general of
the security and disruptive technologies
research center in 2019
prior to joining the nrc she worked for
20 years at defence research and
development canada where she was the
driving force behind the canadian
department of defense quantum science
and technology strategy dr lafave has a
phd in quantum physics from mcmaster
university and completed a postdoctoral
fellowship in quantum chaos theory at
washington state university
on top of this i can say that my own
passion for this science has benefited
from more than 30 years of back and
forth discussion and debate with dr
lafave who has adeptly answered the
endless questions i've had over
talk
the
years
fans
thank you peter
i can always count on you for a a really
fresh introduction
um
so
it's a pleasure to be here of course as
part of this conference and continue to
moderate this panel of experts so what
i'll do is i'll first start by
introducing the panelists
um and we'll go through
several sets of questions and then we
will leave five minutes uh towards the
end
like the audience has any questions uh
to be able to ask the panelists
so i'll start with the introductions
so who we have here we have
panelists from both canada and germany
we're starting with uh nicholas
goodboot he is uh professor budboot is
the head of the
department of engineering physics at
politecnic montreal he is a former
co-president and is a co-founder of
castell optics
and a spin-off of polytechnic mobile and
commercializing optical fiber couplers
for biomedical applications and since
2019 he is also the director of the
institute
so thank you for joining us
um as well we have uh dr andrew x or
andrew ferzman he's a co-founder of one
qubit and serves as its chief executive
officer he was a founding partner of a
vancouver-based vcc firm minor capital
co-funder of
satellogic nano nanosatellites
and co-founder of cloudtel
communications
dr uh hersmann studied economics at the
university of waterloo and philos
philosophy and political sciences at the
university of british columbia prior to
postgraduate programs and technology
studies at singularity university and
financial engineering at stanford
university thank you for joining us
we also have professor moon frit hausfit
he has been the executive director of
the fraunhofer institute for open
communication
since 2014 and holds the chair of open
distributed systems at the technical
university in berlin
he is active in many scientific and
political committees around digitization
and as a director of the weisenbaum
institute for the network society and
principal investigator of the einstein
center digital future
the berlin big data center and the
helmholtz feinstein international berlin
research school in data science
thank you for joining us
and finally we have
nicholas hagemann
he is the managing director of jos
joss quantum sorry for that and
responsible for business development
before that he worked as a management
consultant in different business and
technical areas focusing on software
integration and financial services
he was responsible for several big
projects mostly in the field of trading
and risk management
nicholas worked at the german
german electron cyclotron deci and he
received his degree
in physics with subsidiary subject in
economics from the university of hamburg
thank you for joining us
and so i will uh turn our attention to
the actual questions um and so what i'll
do is i'll start with the first question
and um and go through our our panelists
so um starting with uh why should canada
and germany have a quantum computer
so uh moonfred maybe you could start
with uh
uh with giving us your perspective
well
thank you very much uh bonjourne or
canada from germany
this is as much as i will bother you
with my french
now
i think in in many areas uh quantum
computers will
be
necessary for scientific breakthroughs
now why should you have a national
quantum computer i mean it's very simple
you want to k you want to have uh the
economic benefits that come out of uh
years and decades and of investments in
your in your home country we've seen
this in many places that there has been
a lot of very interesting and good
fundamental research and
the economic benefits then move to
other countries i mean i just take
computer fire science the platform
economy and a lot of other things that
for example were developed in europe in
other places
when it comes to distributed network
systems
all along the world wide web
and who reaps in the benefits so big
companies in the silicon valley now
there's nothing wrong with having a good
sense of business but i think we should
have learned our lesson by now we do a
lot and as we've seen in the previous
presentations a lot of extremely
good and groundbreaking research in
canada and in the eu
and i think it's necessary to secure
the benefits in our economies and then
export it to the us for example
thank you very much andrew
hello yeah and i'll just say i know i'm
around so many erudite people here sadly
i'm not a doctor so i'll just be
addressed as regular andrew through this
but
thank you so much for having me i i
would say that one of the things that's
really interesting about quantum
computing is that we don't yet know
exactly what they're for in the same
sense that you could imagine as people
were toiling away to build the first
vacuum tubes they probably weren't
imagining farmville being played on
facebook you know deep into the future
and so
we suffer from not knowing the potential
applications for these devices yet while
also having some very clear
understanding of areas where
these devices will make a big difference
and one of the best
reasons that i can think especially for
germany to be involved in quantum
computing is that quantum computing is
really about simulating the emergence of
the physical world really the emergence
of things as low level as chemistry
from the world of physics and if you can
think back to all of the amazing
material science and chemistry history
and industry that exists within germany
the material science and raw materials
capabilities of canada these are two
nations that should really benefit from
having a much deeper understanding of
how to command the fundamental forces of
nature to recreate our physical spaces
and that understanding and knowledge is
really going to be very difficult
without quantum computation so this is
one of the very specific answers i think
we can give to this question
thank you
thank you very much
okay let's turn to a different question
uh how do quantum computing quantum
communications and quantum sensing
relate to each other
um and to start uh answering that
question and nicholas
yes thank you uh so first
from the perspective of enteric so this
we are this transdisciplinary institute
in quantum information
bringing together engineers physicists
and
computer scientists
so all these subjects
i think really benefit from the
interplay
uh
it's a complex subject quantum
information is a complex subject
and i think that we gain a lot by uh
bridging
different communities together now my
perspective as an engineer
um
what what have
you know these computers communications
and sensors have in common
uh going into the future it's quite
clear that we will need an underlying
quantum technology an economy of quantum
technology that will support um uh that
will support all these subjects and and
to come back to an
analogy that andrew uh was give you know
mentioning earlier we didn't quite know
in the past what vacuum tubes and then
transistors were for
but they are useful for all kinds of
different things it's going to be true
in quantum technologies is that there
will be common technologies underlying
computation and the other
applications
absolutely okay thank you for that uh
nicholas do you have anything to add
no actually i think nicolas touched all
all points here i mean we as a company
are involved more in the quantum
computation field so
nothing much to add to relate
the three topics to each other
okay
thank you very much
um going to another question how can
industry get involved in quantum
computing and for that i will turn to
nicholas you you again
okay yeah i mean that's a that's a very
relevant point
for for for us and i think for the
industry i mean it's a it's a
push-and-pull game between research and
academia
and to to to know the relevant things to
to to research about going forward into
into industry applications it's very
relevant that people sit together from
different
uh with different experience with
different backgrounds so we see it
currently in a research project uh enac
fund where we um yeah research do
research about quantum algorithms and
energy markets
and um yeah going back and forth with
people from university building uh
quantum computers and thinking about
what are the current borders of uh
classical computation
is is always a challenge to um
yeah to to speak the the same language
of what is needed in the industry what
is the real problem what is the
complexity of the problem and where
quantum computers might benefit
so um
yeah how can industries get in get
involved
three questions maybe to to to ask
yourself as an industry leader um first
does your business model rely on
technology
do you run complex optimization
simulation machine learning tasks on a
regular basis and three are you ready to
invest in research and development
because the technology of quantum
computation might not bring the business
um benefit in the next 12 months but is
rather a long-term
wow those are race good points thank you
for that
uh andrew
thanks yeah i think um it is also really
interesting to notice what's happening
in the uh the world of industry today um
there was a comment earlier about the
tendency for silicon valley to grab
technologies and run with it um this is
already happening there's now five
companies on the quantum hardware side
based out of the united states with
larger than a billion dollar evaluation
there are now two computing companies in
the hardware space that are currently at
higher than a three billion dollar
valuation and a number of these
companies have more cash on their
balance sheets than the combined
munich canadian national quantum
strategy
budgets put together so we're starting
to see small startup companies that
command more resources than entire
national strategies
and so the
ability to link together these efforts
to be able to see these as all different
pieces of the puzzle instead of
competing against one another and to
understand
where are their unique gaps that are
available to be filled by industry where
are there unique gaps that can only be
filled by government or research
institutions and then thinking about a
strategy that empowers all of these
different actors to fulfill their
missions best i think this is really the
place that we're standing today and the
success of our industry will really be
about coordinating all of those
components together
oh that's a very good point thank you
um i'll turn to another question is uh
how does data privacy impact uses and
applications of quantum computing and
for that uh moon freight to you would
you like to start
uh thank you judy
i think especially for industry this is
of paramount importance because uh the
areas that for example optimization and
simulation algorithms will run in
are at the core of the economic models
for a lot of technology companies so
it's really important that the
information is kept in secret if you
transport information into a cloud i
mean you cannot store at least at the
moment information on the quantum
computer but it has to sit very close to
the quantum computer and
it is an enormous amount of of
information that that has to be
transported there
now to be uh
safe and secure in terms of these trade
signals secrets data privacy of course
is of paramount importance
if you then uh
well with
if you then also
process information for example in a
different use case let's say if you go
into traffic management that potentially
can be traced back to individual that's
the same that's the same issue the data
privacy and the security of the data has
to be has to be protected
and how this is done in practice we have
shown or how this could be done as one
example in practice we have shown with
the setup of the
ibm quantum system q here in germany
which is a completely under
european data protection laws
under german uh legislation and we
guarantee that no information gets out
of out of the system
now as soon as there is quantum storage
i mean i'm i'm really not qualified to
talk about quantum storage uh with my
with my background maybe some of the
colleagues here in the discussion then
the chain the game may change change
again and in terms of quantum
communication of course we have heard
already that uh the security protocols
needs need to up their game
to continue to be safe in the future on
the other hand there are also some
really great
opportunities there so quantum
communication as soon as somebody is
tapping your quantum communication
you'll know
or a quantum key distribution may also
help to increase existing networks to
into new security levels so it's it's a
it's a game of threat versus benefit and
i think we are well advised to know as
much as possible what is possible what
can be done technically in this domain
absolutely
um
uh nicholas
yeah that's an that's a that's an
excellent answer
and
we're going towards a cloud model of
quantum computing i don't think that
users will own their own quantum
computer
so it comes back to the first question
that you had
why do we need quantum computers in
canada and germany it touches this point
of of data sovereignty uh this point
that we're we're trying to see in both
countries
as i just learned from from the german
side these requirements legal
requirements to to store sensitive data
uh and public data within the country
and so uh going forward this will most
likely transfer in the quantum computing
realm
and um
philip came and i think covered pretty
much the subject of the threat versus
defenses to the security of quantum
communications um and again uh i i i
enjoyed andrew's comment that now we're
seeing more funding in the private
sector than in the public sector
and we're seeing now the effects
on
the social effects of having uh
you know on the regular internet on the
classical internet the effect of very
large corporations
and i think that's another reason for
governments and funding agencies to be
involved and to keep going the future
some control over
where the field is going in in terms of
privacy and the impact on society
yeah that was a very
good points thank you
um what i think i'll do is uh we we have
a little extra time but this is great
because uh we can turn perhaps right
away to some of the questions that have
been coming into the questions and
answer uh chat and um and sort of take
it from there so why don't i take the
first one because this one is an
important one is that there seems to be
a talent uh shortage in quantum and what
would you recommend is the best way for
someone to get into the field and
in particular what are the types of
barriers that the students could face
um would anybody like to take uh that
question
okay
nicholas
yeah i'll jump first and um
when when we we talk about talent
shortage uh well i think most of us that
i have grown from
academia like university level
um
will soon reach a point we will need a
technical workforce underneath and i
think it's uh it's really time right now
uh when we talk about talent and quantum
information uh to to to train also at
the uh at the technical levels uh for
for uh
all the support we need quantum
programmers we need uh uh
people do maintenance of quantum
computers or quantum communication
systems so that's one aspect
[Music]
for a talent that is very important
thank you
uh yes
uh manfred
well i i think specifically the the mix
of expertise that you need in some of
the domains that nikolas has mentioned
is really really important you know
you can
study quantum physics you can study
quantum informatics you can become an
engineer you can become a computer
scientist but essentially quantum uh
quantum computers are at the crossroads
uh at the borders of all these areas and
what we need to do in the in the
university system that we also come have
to come up with curricula that touch the
essential point so that you have
sufficiently deep knowledge in in the
various areas and that you that we equip
the uh
students
with the necessary tools that they can
actually solve the problems that
practical
quantum computing in industry
is going to is going to
uh they are going to face in these areas
and this is really tricky because also
the different science disciplines need
to start to talk or start more to talk
with each other you know everybody tries
to frame the problem in their own
discipline but this is clearly
insufficient in there and i think it's
also important that
the governments invest into universities
and studies study programs in this area
so that we can educate these experts
there is already a short shortage of
experts if i look if i try to find
people here in berlin
there are a lot a lot of companies that
can pay uh more than i can as a research
center and they they love to go to the
cool places and we need to ensure that
the places we are canada germany the
different cities are the cool places
where people come
we educate our owns and also from
foreign countries the the good people
come to this place
thank you andrew
thanks yeah i would just note that
canada really suffers in some ways from
an embarrassment to riches on this topic
we have these incredible clusters around
the university of british columbia
university of waterloo and the
university of sherbrooke especially but
what we have uh and what we anticipate
is a shortage of the future and so what
we're really trying to do is to find
ways to be able to bring in as many
young people um from this process and to
be able to expose them not just to the
theoretical component but to the sort of
technical business components that are
necessary in order to be a sort of
well-rounded
future
entrepreneur employee researcher in this
space and to be able to take advantage
of this early crop of activity
in order to be able to utilize this to
spread those capabilities through an
even wider group of people and to really
start a flywheel together so the big
part that i look at is how are we going
to be able to reach as many people with
this embryonic ecosystem that we have
today to form the foundation for an even
larger and healthier ecosystem in the
future
that's a very good point
in fact it goes uh really oh uh nicholas
did you have anything to add sorry
before i
turn to another question i just want to
make sure i didn't miss anybody
did you say nicolas or nicole oh sorry
nick's i'll say nicholas and nicolas
well
maybe a pragmatic answer to your to your
question if you
if you are if you are not coming from
the field of quantum mechanics it's
really difficult to understand the
foundations but
my experience that some people
having experience in software
engineering and building classical
algorithms is turning to a specific
problem and think about what can benefit
can quantum computing bring and look at
some fundamental ideas of quantum
computation i mean there are tutorials
about how to solve for example monte
carlo simulations
um with a quantum algorithm and start
with a specific problem and yeah try to
get through because
if you did not study 30 years of quantum
information science it's really hard to
come up with new things
yeah understood
thank you for that
um in fact this uh your answers actually
feed quite nicely into the next question
that came in and the question was
uh could you share what goes into
building a good quantum computing
ecosystem
and i don't know if anybody would like
to take
that question i i i will have a go at it
that's a that's a deep question
it's an exercise that we've seen uh a
lot of effort going into uh in the
province of quebec especially during the
last two years what do we need to build
an ecosystem
uh we need a little bit of everything uh
we need the
we need the solid-state scientists who
also understand quantum mechanics to
work on the basic materials how do you
build a cubit this quantum bit that is
very difficult
and then engineers to to make this work
and for all the the layers on top the
electronics that we need for the control
and and computer scientists
who usually don't know anything about
the hardware uh
who
tell us what how they should be built
how they should be connected how do we
increase protection
um
and and in order to to realize
all that it necessitates a lot of
classical electronics so we need as i
mentioned before uh technical staff
technical staff and engineers to to
design all the need to solve all the
nitty gritty details and the problems
that come up in assembling a quantum
computer
and then we also need to talk about the
users so we've also seen
locally
big efforts to educate potential users
and banks governments uh what will these
be useful for
uh
give examples of algorithms
work with
institutes
who specialize more in the optimization
problems
so yes to build an ecosystem it takes a
little bit of everything and a lot of
dialogue
between all these players
absolutely
ah
moonfree
well uh
you know this is the this is the the 100
000 dollar question uh built how to
build an ecosystem because this means
that you have a lot of scientific
success uh scientific and economic
success at your hands maybe only a small
addition to what nikola said it's also
that you have to
uh you have to
come up with a bit of a coolness factor
as strange as this may sound i mean why
do people go into the
into into silicon valley or so because
it's cool to be in silicon valley why do
they go to ivy league universities all
over the world because it's cool
so i think the first thing is to attract
people
then they will see this is not a simple
problem and it's hard and they need to
learn a lot
specifically from different areas also
as niklas had said if you are not
involved involved for 30 years in in
quantum mechanics it's going to be
difficult but on the other hand you know
there there is this there is this nice
quote by the former president of the
weizmann institute so uh
understand uh no amount of of research
on candlelight would have brought across
electricity so that's the fundamental
that's the hardware that's that's the
tough stuff but understanding the
principle of combustion doesn't
doesn't mean you can build a daimler so
he mentioned that one uh car brand so
i'm not doing
advertisement here and this is exactly
what we need here we unders we need to
understand the the really the basic very
basic research the basic principles but
on the other hand there's a lot of
engineering there's also a lot of
engineering not only in hardware but
also in software to make such a system
successful and a lot of a lot of systems
for example that come from computer
science
weren't even the best possible technical
systems but they were the usable systems
think of the world wide web when tim
berners-lee came up with originality by
the way a physicist by training so
kudos to the physicists
it was really not up to the then
existing technologies in distributed
systems but it was there people could
use it and people could extend it and uh
something incredible developed out of it
and some of the of the largest companies
in the world that we that we have now
and this is something i think you will
need for a successful ecosystem so that
these great ideas also flourish
economically and scientifically
that's a great answer uh i think we have
time for one more answer andrew
uh yeah maybe just finish it off with a
little bit of tough love for us here on
this one which is to say you know i love
the back padding i love all the
congratulatory spirit for the things
that we've done well
but i'd also note that i think we have
something like three or four quantum
valleys represented on this call
i think of that as sort of an
aspirational title and what's likely to
happen
is the thing that made silicon valley
successful
is not the fact that they call
themselves silicon valley it's the fact
that they really took risks that you
know governments were available in order
to help uh you know create demand for
some of these infant technologies along
the way and they did all the things that
we're talking about you know real
deep funding risk taking collaborations
and procurement
the things that we need to emulate about
silicon valley aren't the way that they
describe themselves as blank valley it's
the actual activities of creating some
of these anchor points using the success
in order to create these focus foci
that will
bring talent around them and being able
to really nurture that going forward so
as we're all looking to have the kind of
success that's causing us to name our
activities around a particular place
let's really think about what made that
place successful and whether we're doing
those activities
oh it's a really good point there too
and uh thank you very much uh for all of
your answer thank you for joining us uh
for this uh panel
uh peter i'm going oh
peter i'm going to uh
hand the baton back to you
okay
just
now my video has been halted so i'll
have to wait for the host to start it
there we go
now
having some troubles with that can you
see me julie
excellent thank you
so thank you uh very much julie for for
running that panel and thank you so much
to all the panelists on it for the
insightful discussion on this
fascinating topic
it's a real treat to have so many great
minds together at one time to answer
questions and it looks like i can see
some of the questions in the chat we
probably could have gone on for another
couple of hours
um
so for some closing remarks i'm going to
turn you over to dr julia martin who is
the chief digital resource officer at
the national research council of
canada's emerging technologies division
dr martin has been a researcher and
served in multiple leadership roles in
the digital technologies research center
at the nrc his strategic leadership has
resulted in an increase in the impact of
digital technology research at the nrc
and beyond in addition dr martin has
established research and development
programs drawing interest in
collaboration from universities and
other government departments joel
good day thank you in gutensar
uh as emphasized by uh his excellency
stefan dion at the very beginning
we are here we're all here to strengthen
the partnership in the development of
quantum technologies
for ma i can't make it the whole list
that stefan dion listed but
manufacturing transportation defense and
many other fields
and
i'm going to emphasize three simple
conclusions that i drew from from the
everything that we've heard today uh
and i'll try to do it very quickly
uh as andrew firstman oh so the first
conclusion is that we are at a turning
point
as andrew firstman noted uh early
early on in the panel we don't know
quite yet what quantum technologies are
good for but we know or we have faith
that they're going to lead to scientific
breakthroughs
and we in both countries want to reap
the benefits
and we're looking at this now well one
of the reasons we're looking at this now
is because the quantum computers that
are available now
are powerful enough to exceed what can
be simulated on classical computers in a
couple of cases and we expect that to
increase
and and we expect to see
practical advantages commercially uh
exploitable advantages
and all of this has led to additional
funding from government and we've heard
from venture capitalists maybe more than
government
so a second conclusion is that canada
and germany are seizing the
opportunities
and both countries want to do more so
we've heard that in canada there's this
national quantum strategy
with with the new funding it's adding up
to more than a billion in germany we we
heard about the investment of two
billion
uh and we're we heard
about a lot of the successes so students
and professors and projects
uh and in both countries there is a
robust startup environment as you saw in
michaela mosca's
presentation there are
around 20 startup companies in canada
these are all things that we can
celebrate
and that leads me to my the third
conclusion is that our opportunity is
collaboration we want to create a
vibrant effective ecosystem
and we can all be proud of these
successes but there are gaps and we have
the opportunity to learn from each other
about those gaps the map that tatiana
dr velk put up and
the map that dr mosca put up and the
opportunities all across canada and all
across germany
so thank you
uh i really uh loved the session today
and uh donkey shane
great thank you very much uh joel for
your closing remarks and well uh
turn my video on again
there we go
um i hope you found the event uh
interesting and educational uh quantum
computing and quantum technologies in
general have tremendous potential to
transform and improve our lives and it's
going to be fascinating to watch as
these technologies roll out over the
years
i'd like to note that the embassy of
canada and berlin
in collaboration with the national
research council is putting on a quantum
canadian quantum technology r d
partnering mission to germany in
february of next year this mission will
establish industrial r d collaborations
between canadian and german
organizations with the hopes of future
commercialization i'd be happy to put
you in touch with the embassy in berlin
for more information if you wish
in closing i'd like to say it's been an
honor and a pleasure to be your mc today
i'd like to thank the national research
council staff in munich and members of
the embassy of canada and berlin for
helping to put on this event in
particular my sincere thanks to our
organizing team of petra kovacova
jack poco peck olivier hua jordan khan
and jennifer decker for all their hard
work and dedication in making this event
a success thank you for your time and
attention everyone have a good day
grazie
daniel
and dr
you